[Musique]
oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des clichés méconnu réalisé par une
légende
robert doisneau dans un univers qu'on ne
le connaît pas c'était d'abord des 49 à
52 ans signe un contrat avec le journal
drogue
on lui demandait de faire des sujets sur
la vie mondaine à paris où nous
élargirons peu le sujet mais c'était
surtout à cette époque les mariages chic
enfin la vie mondaine de somptueux bal
et mariage en noir et blanc représentant
un monde que robert doisneau ne
maîtrisait pas toujours on est dans
l'après guerre
c'est à dire qu'à une reprise de la vie
culturelle formidable en france et des
jeunes artistes qui s'appelle bernard
buffet jeanne moreau qui est à la
comédie française michel galabru qui
vient de sortir du conservatoire et
voilà et on lui demande d'aller
photographier tous ces gens là et il est
très heureux de le faire parce que ils
se sont très bien compagnie des artistes
peut-être mieux en compagnie des
duchesses et de comtesses qui marie des
enfants 73 photographie minutieusement
choisis parmi 450 me cliché
à 23 ans après sa disparition
robert-doisneau nous dévoile encore de
nouvelles facettes de son talent